quarante familles campent dans une rue
du 19e arrondissement à paris devant
l'immeuble où ils étaient logés pour
protester contre son état d'insalubrité
le reportage dé google mann eric de
lannion c'est parce qu'elles veulent un
logement décent qu'une quarantaine de
familles ont décidé de camper avec leurs
enfants dans la rue et d'y passer la
nuit
elles vivent ici certaines depuis 18 ans
dans cet immeuble insalubre du 19e
arrondissement de paris un ancien hôtel
meublé ou tout fait défaut cet enfant
avec les pères et les mères cet iphone 9
il habite lada flatbush 12 mccarey lord
a besoin car et c'est normal comment on
arrive à vivre là bas
pourtant ils payent en moyenne 750
francs de loyer par mois selon le comité
des locataires plusieurs enfants
seraient atteints de saturnisme à cause
des peintures anciennes chargé de plomb
nirlo génie expulser les familles sont
sur des listes d'attentes de hlm
certaines depuis 15 ans ballotté entre
les services de la ville de paris et
ceux de la mairie du 19e arrondissement
en bray